Dave from Connecticut writes in about  Penn pineapple apple pen don't you think  it's time Ben excuse me Ben  Bane finally sang Penn pineapple Apple  pan  sincerely Dave from Connecticut I  absolutely am all in favor of Kevin  doing the heavy lifting when it comes to  Penn pineapple apple Penn bein the  villain from Dark Knight Rises again  once again more well now I forget the  name of the movie was a long title yeah  we'll sing Penn pineapple apple Penn by  P Kotaro here VPAP time to shine  I have a pen I have an apple a fierce  one with the other apple pear I have a  pen  for some reason I have a pineapple I  fused that pineapple pear apple  pineapple pear believe this popular pen  pineapple apple pear I should kill you  all for enjoying pineapple apple pear  there you go man and his pain is glory  [Music]  you  [Music]